[Musique]
comme tu es belle avoir 20 ans au pays
des talibans où l'histoire vous venez de
le voir de deux amis Sofia et niggina
qui malgré l'arrivée des talibans au
pouvoir on cherchait jusqu'au bout à
maintenir un semblant de liberté dans un
salon de beauté en plein cœur de Kaboul
avant de choisir l'exil preuve s'il le
fallait de l'oppression dont font
désormais quotidiennement l'objet les
femmes afghane dans leur pays les deux
réalisatrices de ce film sont maintenant
avec nous sur ce plateau de débat doc
Solène chalbon fiority pour commencer
bienvenue à vous vous êtes réalisatrice
grand reporter votre premier reportage
en Afghanistan remonte maintenant à 2011
et vous êtes l'auteur en outre ce film
de ce livre intitulé La femme qui s'est
éveillée une histoire organe ça
n'ouvrage publié chez Flammarion Margaux
Ben est également avec nous vous êtes
vous aussi bien entendu journaliste gore
porter au service étrangers du Figaro
la réalisatrice et spécialiste de
l'Afghanistan vous avez vécu d'ailleurs
une partie de votre vie pour exercer
votre métier bien entendu et vous avez
reçu l'an dernier il faut le noter parce
que c'est le Graal dans notre profession
du Prix Albert Londres et cette fois
c'était pour votre couverture de la
guerre en Ukraine dans les colonnes du
quotidien Le Figaro puis on fait avec
vous amidaman bienvenue à vous aussi
vous êtes journaliste
Algano Suisse vous êtes né à Kaboul vous
êtes revenu en Afghanistan en 2001 après
la chute du premier régime taliban pour
vous y installer jusqu'en 2015 et vous
êtes la fondatrice de radio bigom une
radio pour
pardon et pour les femmes j'ai appris en
préparant cette émission que bégom était
un titre de noblesse c'était aussi le
prénom de votre grand-mère en fait
c'était le nom qu'on donnait aux femmes
des maharajas radio Begum c'est une
radio qui émet depuis Kaboul avec
notamment la diffusion de de cours
radiophonique à raison de 6 heures par
jour qui vont de la cinquième à la
terminale enregistrée en présentiel
comme dans une vraie salle de classe
vous bénéficiez de je crois de
six antennes qui couvrent 10 provinces
sur les 34 que compte l'Afghanistan
aujourd'hui
en fait on a parlé nous un peu de cette
radio on est parti de zéro il y a deux
ans on a il y a deux ans j'ai anticipé
que la situation allait changer
radicalement changé pour le pays bien
sûr je m'attendais pas à aucun aucun
d'entre nous ne nous attendions à ce
cataclysme mais je présais je présumais
que la situation allait avec en
intégrant l'état Liban lorsque les pour
parler entre les Américains et les
talibans ont débuté
en 2020 à Doha on a senti que quelque
chose allait se passer certainement
qu'il fallait compter à nouveau sur ce
sur l'étalement
en Afghanistan et que on parle de tout à
ce moment-là mais pas des droits des
femmes et donc affolé je me suis dit
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait faire pour
justement non seulement avoir une une
présence et comptez et avoir une voix
qui compte et simplement et de faire
entendre notre voix et la radio c'est
imposée de manière tout à fait naturelle
c'est les Nations unies à la fois et
l'UNESCO qui finance vos locaux et vous
employez aujourd'hui 15 afghane pour
animer cette cette radio c'est bien ça
et vous faites-vous des allers-retours
entre la France je partage montrant
entre l'Afghanistan exactement pour être
la chance de vous avoir aujourd'hui sur
sur ce plateau évidemment première chose
qu'on a envie de vous demander
Solène c'est de savoir comment vont
Sofia et une Dina que dev
peut-être pour commencer alors Mélina
est toujours en Allemagne à Hambourg
donc elle apprend l'allemand elle est
elle est elle a toujours très envie de
devenir infirmière même si elle pense
que avec ses compétences il est probable
qu'elle se dirige d'abord vers un salon
de beauté avant de faire autre chose ou
avant peut-être de reprendre des études
Sophia on la voit régulièrement parce
que vous pensez bien contre deux femmes
qui font un film et de femmes qui sont
filmées il y a pas nécessairement une
amitié il y a un écartage important mais
il y a quand même une vraie tendresse il
s'est noué entre nous et Sofia dans la
région parisienne elle est dans la
région parisienne mais elle travaille à
laisser dans un dans un salon de beauté
qui est gare du Nord et c'est transformé
ou pas parce que vous nous laissez
évidemment sur cette information à la
toute fin du film elle est à l'essai
elle est toujours elle est allé ça
toujours c'était plutôt pour une
question administrative fallait attendre
qu'elle est son statut de réfugié
qu'elle a désormais et elle est elle est
pleine de vie elle est elle mord la vie
elle a très envie de réussir d'apprendre
de parler français le plus vite possible
et elle fait presque oui elle fait
partie un peu de notre quotidien
maintenant à toutes les deux on va
revoir un tout petit extrait c'est très
court c'était la promesse des talibans
une fois qu'ils étaient arrivés au
pouvoir et c'est la radio afghan qui
s'exprime alors que vos deux personnages
sont dans un taxi
à Kaboul
ce tournage a commencé au lendemain de
l'arrivée au pouvoir des talibans le 15
août 2021 les nouveaux maîtres de
l'Afghanistan ont fait une promesse au
monde entier ils ont changé
[Musique]
scolaire en Afghanistan au moment où
nous avons cet échange et cette rentrée
scolaire elle va se faire sans les
jeunes femmes de plus de 12 ans et les
femmes ne vont pas pouvoir non plus à
nouveau rentrer à l'université voilà où
on en est promesse non tenues
mais enfin tout le monde s'y attendait
c'est à dire que les talibans dès lors
qu'ils sont commencé à négocier avec les
Américains leurs sorties en fait et la
sortie de toutes les armées
internationales d'Afghanistan ils ont
commencé par montrer patte blanche assez
rigide en sorte de nouveaux groupes
taliban talibans 2.0 un terme qui qui
est revenu souvent dans la bouche de
certains observateurs étrangers etc donc
ils faisaient ce genre de promesses aux
Afghans mais également à la communauté
internationale pour voilà pour asseoir
petit à petit et leur pouvoir est
légitimer quelque part ce qui est
cyniquement voilà une réalité légitimée
le départ des étrangers qui se disait
finalement
on quitte l'Afghanistan mais les
talibans ne sont pas ceux qu'ils étaient
dans les années 90 avec voilà toutes les
images qu'on a des lapidations publiques
etc on les on les laisse mais ils
arriveront à diriger le pays sans être
les monstres qu'ils étaient bien
évidemment cette promesse n'a pas du
tout été tenue dès les premiers mois de
leur de leur arrivée au pouvoir les
talibans ont commencé à restreindre les
droits des femmes à arrêter les
journalistes les torturer voilà
interdire toute forme de manifestation
donc là
on assiste dans une partie de votre film
non plus lieu aujourd'hui à Kaboul
notamment ou est-ce que des femmes
prennent encore le risque de descendre
dans la rue et de manifester comme on
l'a vu dans votre film d'abord il y a
encore des manifestations épars parce
qu'on a pu en couvrir avant et après
celle que vous avez dans ces images mais
encore une fois nous c'est notre façon
de résister numériquement ça vraiment
pas grand chose en Afghanistan parce que
c'est fille prennent des risques
inconsidérés enfin en tout cas très
courageux puisque les talibans les
réprimes dans la violence mais il y a
d'autres formes de résistance et ça
aussi c'est à dire que nous on pense
peut-être c'est la seule résistance
parce qu'elle est visible mais les
Afghans résistent comme Amida Aman en
voilà en continuant de travailler en
diffusant des contenus éducatifs en
continuant quand même vraiment à tenir
ces écoles clandestine qui se chiffre
maintenant quasiment dizaines de
milliers enfin on pense qu'on sera à
15000 l'année prochaine donc il y a une
résistance qui a une résistance moins
visible mais qui est extrêmement
présente et nous deux je pense qui est
vraiment ce qui nous ce qui nous donne
vraiment de de l'espoir en fait depuis
des mois parce que c'est la seule
résistance à laquelle on assiste
vraiment et qui continue très
progressivement sont nos yeux à voilà
quand même à prendre de l'espace cette
résistance qui perdure alors Kaboul
n'est pas non plus l'Afghanistan est-ce
que ce qui vient d'être dit là est vrai
pour l'ensemble du pays où que
c'est vraiment vrai pour Kaboul qui est
la capitale de la savoir que les
talibans se font un malin plaisir de de
d'instaurer ses règles pour les femmes
des villes principalement c'est elle qui
veulent mater et finalement c'est elle
les plus résistantes je ne dis pas qu'on
dans les provinces dans les provinces il
en existe mais je pense que les
pressions vous sont beaucoup plus sont
beaucoup plus dures et et il y a et là
pour le coup il n'y a pas du tout de
témoin encore à Kaboul nous avons des
témoins donc on peut manifester on peut
s'exposer un peu mais ailleurs dans les
villes du Nord ou de l'ouest du pays où
effectivement il y a quand même beaucoup
de femmes éduquées dont la vie a
énormément joué mais ces femmes là elles
ont beaucoup plus elles sont beaucoup
instrument beaucoup plus pour leur vie
alors et quand on voit que les femmes
accabulent sont fatigués et commencent
justement un petit peu voilà être
petit à petit à se rendre dans laquelle
dans les autres villes c'est déjà fait
je l'ai évidemment précisé radio bégom
diffusent des cours pour l'éducation
pour les femmes afghans elle reçoit
aussi le témoignage de final il y a une
forme de libre aux paroles que vous
Distel est-ce que cette résistance est
perceptible à travers leur propos tenus
sur votre radio aujourd'hui pour une
partie de ces femmes énormément ces
femmes elles nous appelles nous avons
des émissions de libre antenne de
soutien psychologique de conseils santé
conseil spirituel et énormément les les
femmes Apple pour parler de leur
mal-être de leurs problèmes de
dépression de et surtout des jeunes
femmes nous appellent des jeunes filles
qui sont désespérées de voir leur école
fermée et maintenant des jeunes femmes
parce qu'il y a aussi les universités
qui sont enfermées vous avez parlé on a
parlé de la rentrée scolaire mais aussi
à rentrer universitaire qui a eu lieu
une deux semaines avant mais et
les femmes ne sont interdites d'y
retourner donc là les
les deux protagonistes du documentaire
aurait été en a vu une histoire elles
auraient dû cesser leurs études et c'est
les et toutes ces et là le le justement
ce dernier coup a vraiment fini par
vraiment à semer les femmes parce que
jusqu'à maintenant interdire le niveau
collège et nous on le ressent parce que
justement on donne des coups c'est cours
radiophoniques à l'attention des
collégiennes mais au départ on avait
commencé à son se douter que ça allait
aussi s'appliquer à l'université donc
tant que c'est que le collège qui
impactait c'est déjà énorme mais on
pourrait se dire c'est pas grave je fais
je termine mon collège tant bien que mal
et je me présente encore au concours
d'entrée et au moins j'ai une chance de
continuer les études au delà à
l'université mais même ça ça leur est
complètement coupé donc ça devient très
difficile de continuer à motiver les les
adolescents et les jeunes vers des
études même en ligne par parfois est-ce
qu'on peut croire raisonnablement que le
pouvoir va rétablir l'accès
également dans les provinces je veux
dire les
gouverneurs talibans de certaines
provinces ne sont pas forcément sur la
même ligne que ceux d'autres provinces
donc il y a des petites mutations qui
vont peut-être s'opérer localement avec
par exemple l'accès à l'éducation qui
sera peut-être un tout petit peu plus
accepté même officieusement dans
certaines régions que dans d'autres le
problème est que la pression est aliment
sont beaucoup moins la pression de la
communauté internationale c'est-à-dire
qu'ils ne sont plus obligés de montrer
pas de Blanche ils ne sont plus obligés
de montrer qu'ils sont ouverts qu'ils
sont voilà qui sont en faveur de
l'éducation des petites filles des
femmes etc donc finalement tous fera
voilà selon le bon vouloir de tels
gouverneur de tels gouverneur talibans
etc mais globalement même s'il existe
des dissensions au sein du leadership
taliban globalement on parle quand même
d'un groupe extrémiste qui s'est battu
pendant 20 ans pendant plus de 20 ans
pour réasseoir leur modèle de son modèle
de une société qui est extrêmement enfin
je veux dire qui est totalement
moyenâgeux et donc on ne peut pas
vraiment s'attendre à ce que les
talibans d'eux-mêmes lutte pour
faciliter l'accès à l'éducation des
filles même si dans certaines provinces
voilà c'est ces écoles clandestine dont
on parlait Solène sont plus ou moins
officiellement officieusement tolérée on
ne peut pas s'attendre que à ce que les
talibans de même voilà
mettent en forme des
réformes transforme voilà la loi leur
perception de la société qu'ils ont mis
tant d'années à réasseoir et vous nous
dites il y a des dissensions au sein du
pouvoir taliban est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire un peu plus sur ces
dissensions en fait et que ce qu'elle
peut lui laisser espérer pour les femmes
d'abord
des dissensions et dissensions et ils
existent de fait puisque la situation de
l'Afghanistan hormis la question de
l'éducation des filles n'est pas du tout
idéal c'est à dire qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est pour ça d'où les
réserves qu'on a à nous c'est que
malheureusement dans une situation où
90% des Afghans ont besoin d'une aide
d'urgence aujourd'hui que ce soit en
termes de nourriture ou de logements
dans la mesure où la famille a frappé
l'Afghanistan dans
seulement les Afghans ont faim mais en
plus quand même il faut quand même
regarder ce qui se passe c'est à dire
qu'en plus c'est pas la peine déjà c'est
pas la peine pour nous c'est pas la
peine parce que moi en fait je me
demande qu'il y a inventé la paix là si
c'est la paix c'est la paix violente si
c'est une paix qui enferme 20 millions
de femmes mais en plus c'est pas la
peine militaire non plus parce que en
fait Kaboul maintenant est dans une
insécurité perpétuelle avec des
attentats je rappelle que 30 jeunes
filles ont perdu quand même la vie à la
fin de l'année dernière dans un attentat
à la bombe dans un institut donc et il y
a fréquemment des ambassades des voilà
des des petits attentats qui ne sont en
plus pas répertoriés quand il se passe
en dehors de Kaboul parce qu'il y a
beaucoup moins de journalistes en
Afghanistan parce que les journalistes
subissent une pression folle quand il
couvre ses attentats donc en fait les
talibans ils ont tous avec des problèmes
de gouvernance extrêmement fort avec
cette émir depuis quand dark qui entouré
d'une cour qui ne franchement qui ne
reflète pas l'entièreté du mouvement
alors qu'elle soit toute puissante et
souveraine c'est clair parce que sinon
on aurait bien vu plus évidemment de de
discours alternatif mais ce qui est
certain c'est que prioritairement là ils
sont plutôt sur des enjeux de
gouvernance de sécurité et aussi de
d'appréhender la pauvreté sachant qu'en
plus ils sont quand même suicidaires
parce que là on a parlé de l'éducation
mais nous franchement ce qui nous a
encore plus choqué que la décision que
l'interdit sur l'éducation parce que ça
d'une certaine manière on l'attendait il
frappait les femmes des villes les fils
les filles des villes pour les talibans
c'est de toute façon c'est les dépravés
qu'il faut enfin châtier maintenant que
le djihad est terminé mais en fait
d'interdire des femmes de travailler à
l'intérieur des ONG ça veut dire que
vous interdisez des facto des femmes de
bénéficier des distributions de
nourriture d'urgence et donc là en fait
ils s'en prennent aux pauvres donc en
plus il se s'aborde complètement donc
c'est vrai que dans ce contexte là on a
très
nous en tout cas on est certain que ça
ne viendra pas de nos pressions on a
très peu d'espoir de voir les les écoles
réouvrir dans le courant de cette année
qui vient de s'écouler en tout cas
l'année scolaire on a vu quand même il y
avait des quelques dysfonctions au
niveau de l'éducation à l'éducation ne
fait justement l'interdiction des la
fermeture des écoles ne fait absolument
pas l'unanimité au sein du groupe c'est
pas du tout absolument pas pour les
défendre mais c'est vrai que c'était un
sujet de friction il y a eu des voix qui
s'étaient élevées des voies de
importante voilà des des chefs des chefs
talibans quand même bien placés etc mais
malheureusement là on arrive à la à la
date de la rentrée scolaire
malheureusement on se on
se retrouve face à un silence un silence
lourd et on attend de savoir ce qui se
passe mais il y a pas de communication
c'est ça qui est terrible donc est-ce
que ils ont réussi à trouver un terrain
d'entente je ne sais pas mais c'est
triste parce que on s'attendait à ce que
justement que le débat soit un peu plus
monte un peu plus et que les voix
s'élèvent justement maintenant
malheureusement là au moment on les
attend le plus elles sont il y a un
silence de plomb est-ce que les
Occidentaux et en l'occurrence les
Américains qui avaient tout de même
ces fameuses négociations de DOA avec
les talibans conditionnent à certains
modèles à la condition des femmes
aujourd'hui et la condition des femmes
futures est-ce que ça reste d'actualité
ça et alors déjà
les depuis le départ les toutes les
institutions internationales la Banque
mondiale l'ONU etc on mise en place des
systèmes pour contourner les enfin pour
contourner mais pour pour acheminer de
l'aide humanitaire basique aux Afghans
et aux Afghans malgré les sanctions
contre le gouvernement taliban donc
voilà donc la communauté internationale
c'est c'est organisé pour ça pour
continuer à venir en aide au moins un
minimum au pays ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui c'est que avec cette cette
dernière mesure qui a évoqué Hamida qui
est toucher les femmes de travailler
pour des ONG on voit bien que les
talibans ont pris l'ascendant sur la
communauté internationale d'une certaine
manière parce qu'un certain nombre
d'organisations de grosses organisations
qui avaient une assise dans le pays qui
qui parlementait avec les talibans
depuis avant même que les talibans
négocient officiellement avec les
Américains dans tout un tas de provinces
de districts contrôlées par l'État Liban
pendant très longtemps les grosses
organisations internationales devaient
composer avec ces gouverneurs fantômes
comme on les appelait et donc
aujourd'hui c'est négociations là c'est
liens-là et bien il y a eu une espèce de
transmutation qui s'est faite assez
rapidement finalement des liens qui sont
érodés et finalement ce sont les
talibans qui ont qui qui ont l'ascendant
aujourd'hui qui peuvent décider qui
travaillent pour les ONG qui est en
mesure d'être employée etc et comme
d'habitude les femmes dans cette état
complètement failli on prend une crise
économique et s'est transformée en crise
humanitaire gouvernée par en groupe
enfin qui était un groupe insurgé un
groupe armé qui est devenu voilà qui qui
s'est muet en région du pays alors que
bon les trois quarts ne sont eux-mêmes
pas allés au lycée voilà qui et qui
tente de gouverner ce pays les femmes
sont au bout de la chaîne alimentaire et
ce sont les premières victimes de tout
ça qui soutient les talibans aujourd'hui
alors la bouche beaucoup parlé du Qatar
parce qu'il a eu un rôle intermédiaire
dans les négociations notamment entre
Américains et talibans je voudrais
savoir qui soutient ce régime
aujourd'hui alors déjà soutenir le
régime d'abord personne n'a reconnu ce
régime donc si vous voulez là vous allez
à la Kaboul demain les seuls vraiment
diplomates que vous voyez diplomate
d'ailleurs c'est pas vraiment des
diplomates en tout cas les agents que
vous voyez sur place et qui continuent
d'entretenir des liens économiques forts
sont les chinois mais bon ils étaient
ils étaient aussi en lien avec la
République afghane Afghanistan
commune aussi avec la vie très
importante que les Chinois essayent
d'ailleurs de d'entretenir et de faire
vivre depuis des années donc en fait les
liens avec la Chine sont les liens les
plus étroits il y a eu bien sûr des il y
a historiquement avec le Pakistan des
liens extrêmement forts historiquement
aussi avec le Qatar sur des degrés très
différents mais des liens très forts je
vous rappelle que c'est le Qatar qui
héberge tous les pourparlers avec les
talibans quasiment étalés sur sur deux
ans et même ça remonte à avant mais pour
les pour les rencontres mais en réalité
eux-mêmes ceux-là parce que tout le
monde a imaginé nous les premières on
avait bien compris que les Occidentaux
ils allaient pas encore une fois faire
croire au talibans que c'est qu'ils
allaient réussir à les influencer sur la
question de l'éducation mais les
pakistanais et les Catari ont envoyé des
émissaires les Pakistanais notamment qui
sont qui peuvent être très proches des
talibans parce qu'il y a une très grosse
communauté pachtung qui est détenue
taliban en au Pakistan Ils ont envoyé
vraiment des docteurs en religion des
types qui venaient de Karachi vous voyez
qui faisaient le voyage qui était reçu
très très correctement par les talibans
et qui venaient leur rappeler tout
simplement que la chariate commande
d'éduquer ta fille de prendre soin du
corps de ta femme enfin des basiques
coraniques quoi et en fait à chaque fois
ces hémisphères là et le Qatar on sait
que le Qatar via lacher ramosa ont aussi
vraiment essayé
d'influencer l'état libre là-dessus il
ne se passe rien parce que les talibans
sont tout puissants de pression j'ai
l'impression plus il y a une pression
extérieure puisse braque aussi parfois
on a vu dans certaines provinces il y a
quelques où il y a moyen de négocier ou
des autorités ou les la population
locale a réussi au même des
organisations des ONG ont pu négocier
localement pour un peu plus de
flexibilité par exemple pour le travail
pour la distribution alimentaire où ils
ont pu autoriser les femmes justement
participer et même on a vu parfois
durant l'année écoulée quelques écoles
qui étaient mais vraiment au
compte-goutte mais c'était c'est
vraiment au cas par cas donc lorsque on
n'est pas en lumière
on peut peut-être espérer quelque chose
et encore pas donc toutes les régions
dans certaines régions du pays plutôt
dans les pays dans les dans les
provinces du Nord où il y a un petit peu
plus de flexibilité ils doivent se
montrer aussi un peu plus flexibles avec
la population parce que il faut savoir
que les talons viennent leur fief et
sont les villes du Sud principalement la
ville de Grondin capitale religieuse on
peut dire les choses comme ça voilà tout
à fait le capital économique capital
économique et il y a quand même une
grande différence de enfin une grande il
y a une différence d'attitude mortalité
par rapport aux femmes le travail des
femmes et la place des femmes dans la
société et peut-être dans ces provinces
là ils doivent montrer un petit peu plus
flexible mais encore et encore ce que ce
que je voulais justement appuyer c'est
que plus on leur met en leur impose une
pression on leur fait alors les menaces
de couper le peu de de dettes qu'il y a
et en fait
je crois que c'était pas vrai je pense
que c'est quand même souhaitable enfin
en tout cas si on veut pas que les
Afghans soient complètement contenu
isolé du monde c'est à dire à la fois
privé d'éducation privée de pouvoir
sortir du pays etc on a quand même je
pense on a intérêt à souhaiter que les
talibans restent en lien quand même
étroit avec les pays frontaliers et
surtout les pays musulmans c'est vrai
que là je pense pas que ce sont braqués
ils se braque avec nous très clairement
avec les occidentaux les visites en
réalité qui ont eu lieu et c'était
vraiment des visites de courtoisie mais
simplement c'est aussi quelque chose
qu'on a essayé de montrer dans le film
c'est pas du tout qu'une question de
religion c'est à dire que les talibans
dans leurs éléments de langage si vous
faites attention à ce qu'ils disent ils
disent tout le temps en accord avec la
loi islamique et les coutumes afghane et
en fait c'est la fin de cette phrase qui
fait qu'on perd pied c'est la fin de
cette phrase qui fait que les qatari en
réalité n'arrivent pas à se faire
entendre ou que les Pakistanais
n'arrivent pas non plus à influer
c'est-à-dire que les talibans sont quand
même le fruit de code tribaux qui sont
très très existants en Afghanistan qui
régissent des régions entières qui par
moments sont beaucoup plus sévères
encore que la charia et en fait c'est
cette là c'est coutume là qui qu'ils
mettent en fait qu'ils érigent entre
comme une distance entre vous et eux et
qui fait que d'une certaine manière a
bien des égards vous n'arrivez pas du
tout à communiquer pourquoi les talibans
veulent rendre invisible les femmes
c'est une lecture
particulière de l'islam qui les amène à
vouloir rendre invisible les femmes
c'est ce que disait Solène tout à
l'heure c'est que les talibans c'est un
c'est un groupe extremiste religieux qui
veut imposer un modèle de société basé
sur une certaine lecture de la charia
effectivement mais c'est également un
groupe nationaliste ethno nationaliste
page toon en très grande majorité et qui
veut réasseoir les les valeurs enfin
réintégrer les valeurs afghans ou les
supposés valeurs afghans de certains
groupes afghan et donc c'est un espèce
de de pot pourri de de valeurs qui qui
qui sont puisés dans dans le Coran dans
une certaine
une lecture extrêmement rigoriste du
Coran mais également dans voilà dans des
des traditions ancestrales pachtoune
donc majoritairement de l'Est du pays
mais enfin voilà et donc ils ont ils ont
ils ont constitué à partir de tous ces
éléments-là leur modèle de société qui
est extrêmement rigoriste qui veut faire
disparaître les femmes qui les effacer
de de voilà de de la sphère publique et
tout ce qui s'ensuit donc c'est à
l'interdiction du travail des femmes ou
l'interdiction d'études des filles des
femmes etc c'est pas l'islam qui impose
c'est une tradition c'est une tradition
en fait pour eux c'est une tradition
c'est une tradition qu'il estime en
agression parce qu'il faut pas oublier
qu'il vienne d'un milieu très rural et
là nous voyons la confrontation entre la
ruralité et le les urbains et les et la
population des villes et ces deux modes
de vie qui se confrontent
effrayant celui-là aussi c'est la
conséquence de tout ce qui a été décrit
dans ce film et ce qu'on vient de se
dire à l'instant une à deux femmes se
donnerait la mort aujourd'hui tous les
jours bien sûr chaque jour on
Afghanistan cette détresse s'exprime sur
vos ongles tous les jours tous les jours
grâce à nos sur nos autres sur tous les
médias nous proposons des soutiens
psychologiques et je vous assure que
c'est on est assailli d'appel ah ça a
été surtout à chaque fois qu'il y a un
décret qui et qui tombe qui est avec une
nouvelle interdiction et là de nouveau
c'est c'est le c'est les appels c'est
les c'est les c'est ce sont les jeunes
femmes qui se donnent la mort
aujourd'hui celles qui n'ont pas pu
choisir l'exil
bien sûr parce que qui a vu sa vie
complètement bouleversée ce sont les
filles ce sont Sofia et niggina vous
voyez ce sont pas les filles à la
campagne les filles à la campagne sont
soumises à bien d'autres défis à
commencer par
bien sûr le fait d'approvisionnement de
nourriture mais les filles qui ont tout
d'un coup qui ont en fait qui sont
passés du jour à la nuit quoi je veux
dire je peux pas dire ça avec des mots
plus simples c'est à dire
25 celle qui comme vous comme nous comme
nos cousines nos nièces nos enfants nos
filles en fait ce sortent le matin pour
aller à l'école dans un pays où il y a
pas de sociabilité pour les femmes
c'est-à-dire qu'on parle on met tous les
interdits sur le même niveau mais être
interdit de parc ça embête Sofia niggina
et une centaine de de filles à Kaboul
l'école il faut bien comprendre que la
grande réussite l'une des seules de ces
20 dernières années c'était l'école 5
fois plus de gamines scolarisé dans
l'enseignement secondaire en Afghanistan
en 20 ans donc ces fila le seul espace
pour voir ses amis le seul espace de la
socialisation il est il vous est il vous
est complètement fermé et en plus donc
elles sont recluses dans des foyers et
dans des sociétés dans une société qui
est encore quand même n'oublions pas
gangrener par la violence 40 ans de
violence que vous portez votre cher
vraiment une filiation et qui très
souvent se répercute dans le foyer avec
un phénomène de violence domestique
complètement fou et
les entiers les antidépresseurs que vous
achetez pour une poignée vous voyez en
bas de chez vous donc c'est vrai que ça
crée une détresse psychologique et
psychique qui est très très douloureuse
à voir et surtout pour nous qui est
neuve parce que c'est les Afghans n'ont
pas vraiment cette culture là quoi les
femmes les jeunes femmes comme
sauvegards ninjila qui choisissent
l'exil combien
sont-elles aujourd'hui en Afghanistan
est-ce qu'on peut estimer leur nombre
leur moi je saurais pas estimer leur
nombre je pense que c'est leur immense
majorité je pense que quasiment 100% des
jeunes femmes comme Sofia niggina
veulent quitter l'Afghanistan ou il faut
vraiment se représenter que pendant 20
ans on les a abreuvés de rêves des
milliards et des milliards et des
milliards de dollars ont été déversés
dans ce dans ce pays pour donner des
opportunités d'éducation des stages dans
des ambassades des échanges des cours de
dumb po
donc ce sont plein de femmes qu'on a
abreuvé de rêves de projets de et d'un
futur voilà lumineux et modernisé et
tout d'un coup du jour au lendemain il y
a ce coup près qui est tombé et donc des
jeunes femmes comme Sofia comme niggina
qui elle-même son petit peu différente
l'une et l'autre avec des rêves
différents des passés différents etc
toutes ces femmes là ont vu leur futur
complètement
nié et sans aucune perspective de sortie
du tunnel donc je pense qu'il y a il y a
des dizaines de milliers pour ne pas
dire des centaines de milliers de femmes
en Afghanistan aujourd'hui qui veulent
sortir ce qui est certain c'est
qu'aujourd'hui c'est très difficile
c'est devenu encore plus compliqué
qu'avant pour elle de sortir
d'Afghanistan déjà une femme ne peut
plus voyager seule si elle veut sortir
du pays elle doit être accompagnée
impérativement par un chaperon donc
toutes les femmes qui veulent s'extraire
de cette condition mais qui n'ont pas la
chance d'avoir un père un frère un homme
de leur famille qui qui veut bien les
accompagner pour franchir la frontière
pour prendre l'avion pour franchir la
frontière terrestre à aller au Pakistan
que ça déjà elles sont bloquées ne
peuvent pas voyager ensuite obtenir un
visa c'est devenu extrêmement onéreux la
corruption est dans voilà aujourd'hui
obtenir un visage ça coûte des centaines
et des centaines de dollars ce qui est
totalement hors de portée pour
l'écrasante majorité des Afghans et des
Afghans aussi c'est possible c'est
plutôt les hommes
on investit plutôt sur un homme la
famille ce cotise et paye le passeport
ou le visa d'un homme qu'on envoie
l'homme pour travailler et surtout juste
pour continuer le parcours du combattant
qu'évoque Margaux elles arrivent au
Pakistan qui est un des pays qui leur
permet de sortir c'est ce qu'on a vu
dans le fond voilà et en fait c'est pas
le cas de défi qui ont réussi à partir
mais elles ont tendance suite des mois
pour être en fait elles sont reçues à
une ambassade comme notre ambassade de
France notre consulat français au
Pakistan elles attendent des mois avant
de savoir si elles peuvent partir donc
en fait nous qui passons quand même
votre temps à pleurer sur le sort des
femmes afghanes un des moyens notamment
qu'on pourrait quand même développer
pour leur venir en aide ce serait de
renforcer nos équipes consulaires là-bas
pour que les filles puissent partir
facilement et ne pas traîner des mois au
Pakistan prise dans des réseaux de
prostitution des marchands de sommeil
etc on ne fait pas parce que notre
ministère de l'Intérieur en France
considère que d'accueillir des Afghans
c'est pas prioritaire il faut bien
comprendre aussi que nous on pourrait
faire bien davantage pour les Afghans
sur la politique d'asile et qu'on ne le
fait pas du tout et ça depuis quand même
18 mois et ce qui est très intéressant
aussi c'est que certains pays européens
comme le Danemark n'est pas non plus
voilà un chantre de l'accueil en tout
cas récemment qui ne voilà et certains
pays donc comme le Danemark ont adopté
cette ce concept de de d'asile
inconditionnel c'est-à-dire qu'une femme
afghane aujourd'hui elle peut demander
l'asile et lui est donné et le les
femmes afghans qui vous demanderont ce
type d'asile ce sont souvent des femmes
se sont dans leur écrasante majorité des
femmes qui se projettent en France dans
différents pays européens parce qu'elles
déjà soit elle parle déjà un peu
l'anglais où elles ont la capacité elles
ont des métiers déjà ils ont fait des
études qui leur permettront de
s'installer dans ces pays donc ce sont
des femmes qui ont des projets
spécifiques qui arriveront à s'intégrer
à des sociétés dont elle rêve depuis
toute petite qui est
ce sont des projets qui de toute façon
étaient voilà leur perspectives
puisqu'elles auraient dû participer
voilà ces projets éducatifs etc qu'on
leur faisait miroiter donc aujourd'hui
enfin ce serait quand même une bonne
idée de se pencher sur cette question de
l'asile inconditionnel pour ne pas que
toutes ces femmes qui aujourd'hui se
suicident par milliers par dizaines de
milliers puissent aspirer à ce qu'on
leur promettait il y a encore un an et
demi deux ans de toute façon elles
veulent toutes retourner en Afghanistan
soyez en certain
merci beaucoup à toutes les deux pour ce
documentaire comme tu es belle avoir 20
ans au pays des talibans qu'on a vu dans
ce cette émission des badogues merci à
vous aussi bien entendu d'avoir été
parmi nous et longue vie hein radio
Bégum elle apporte beaucoup au final sur
place oui on rappelle que votre radio
émette depuis depuis Kaboul
et justement c'est des neguinas et des
Sofia qu'on qu'on à qui on répond qu'on
fait bosser elles sont les femmes qui
travaillent à la radio bécom c'est
vraiment ces jeunes femmes là elles ont
à peu près le même âge un peu plus un
peu moins voilà c'est c'est les mêmes
profils vos réaction ça sera sur hashtag
des battoc sur Twitter j'imagine
qu'elles seront nombreuses nous inviter
seront là pour répondre à ces réactions
merci à sel massalik qui comme à
l'accoutumée m'a aidé à préparer cette
émission moi je vous retrouverai pour un
nouveau débat doc et ça sera bien
entendu avec son documentaire et son
débat à très bientôt
[Musique]